hey guys this is my dog's Yves he's
going to join me today I'm my review of
Megan levy I think he's a little nervous
he's never been in this room before but
he's a good boy
Megan levy comes to us from the director
of blackfish which was a very Syrian
powerful documentary and this story is
about a marine by the name of Megan Lee
be played by kate mara and her
bomb-sniffing dog named Rex now when I
explained that pot to my wife she was
like nope can't do it can't see it that
little too much for me which I can
understand because we're both dog lovers
and I won't lie there were times when
this movie was a little hard to watch
but the performances especially by kate
mara and by i'm assuming the multiple
dogs that played rex were so good that
it really got me invested in their story
it's also not too sappy or melodramatic
which is often the biggest complaint I
hear about films like this and rely on a
lot of emotion because dogs are just so
cute and in the case of this film they
did such an excellent job maintaining a
sense of realism you get to see Megan as
she's training to become a marine you
get to see her as she's training with
Rex and you see that bond developed
between them and so it's not just about
the dog is so cute and oh my god I hope
it doesn't get hurt I was concerned
about that going in but legitimately
kate mara gave one of the best
performances that I've seen from her and
unlike a lot of films this one did a
fantastic job at showing the true bond
that can grow between a human and an
animal and I think only someone who
truly loves animals can understand that
others might look at that and find it a
little bit too melodramatic but in the
case of myself I was wrapped up in it
the battle sequences were also very
intense because you have a lot of
suspenseful sequences where Rex is
sniffing out bombs and looking for mines
and other explosive devices and it adds
a sense of tension that you don't
normally get in a war film because it
shows a side of war that we're not used
to seeing in film now there was a film
recently called max that I didn't see so
I can't comment on if they were very
similar but this one in particular I
felt was successful because it created a
great character and Megan levy who is a
real marine but it also presented that
bond that genuinely felt real and it
didn't feel like it was
trying to be two-tier jerky even though
I will admit I did tear up it didn't
seem like it was just trying to tug on
my heartstrings only because the thermal
also takes the time to show Megan's
normal life
my only real issues with the film is
that it sometimes speeds through things
very quickly it shows her as a restless
youth living with her mom and all of a
sudden she's training to be a Marine
these things happen very quickly a lot
of really emotional things are shown
through montages or passage of time
through texts and sometimes that can get
a little annoying because I like the
idea of feeling the characters more
feeling the progression of time but the
film is already almost 2 hours so I can
understand these edits and these cuts
also there's a romance that develops in
the film that I didn't think went
anywhere if it was based in reality
while I understand including it but
sometimes you can cut certain things if
that's true it felt like the one aspect
of this movie that just seemed a little
bit too much like a movie like oh she
also meets this bully while she's
bonding with Rex it just didn't really
feel very realistic to me but I was
touched by this movie kate mara gave one
of the best performances of her career
the action sequences were pretty
white-knuckled and more intense than I
expected and it did a great job of
showing the true bond that can develop
between a human in the animal without
making it seem too melodramatic or sappy
I'm going to give Megan levy a B+ guys
thank you so much as always for watching
and thank you for being a trooper and
sticking with me in this review I just
thought it'd be fun for you guys to meet
my dog since this movie is about a
German Shepherd and he's half Sheppard
himself so thank you for being a good
boy guys thank you so much as always for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes
and are you about done geez are you
about done I think you suck with this
review
[Music]